pour affronter la troisième vague de
l'épidémie de kovy 19 emmanuel macron a
promis dix mille lits de réanimation
dans tout le territoire contre 7665
actuellement et c'est aux soignants déjà
épuisé par cette crise sanitaire que le
président de la république à demander de
nouveaux efforts le nombre de lits en
réanimation a déjà été porté à 7 milles
et je veux ici remercié les étudiants en
médecine les retraités le service de
santé des armées tous les volontaires de
la réserve sanitaire
tous sont mobilisés seront mobilisés de
manière accrue pour porter dans les
prochains jours notre capacité à un peu
plus de dix mille et en particulier
aussi avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
capacités d'accueil dans certains
hôpitaux parisiens
cet objectif de 2000 335i de réanimation
supplémentaires avait déjà été évoquée
le 28 octobre dernier lors de la
deuxième vague née à ce moment-là 7000
places en réanimation avait suffi
aujourd'hui avec la flambée de
l'épidémie cet objectif est il
réalisable
lors de la première vague le nombre de
lits dans réanimation occupé en france a
dépassé elle les 10000 mais deux régions
étaient principalement touché l'île de
france et le grand test ce qui avait
permis à l'exécutif de déplacer des
patients vers d'autres régions ou à
l'étranger notamment grâce à l'aide des
tgv médicalisé mais aujourd'hui la
situation est plus critique car c'est
tout le territoire qui est concerné
alors difficile de faire plus
lorsqu'on sait que pour certaines
régions la limite est déjà atteinte
notamment dans les hauts de france où la
capacité est des services de réanimation
et saturé à 95 % en ile-de-france on
envisage de monter de 1700 à 2200 50
places en réanimation sachant que 79%
sont déjà occupés la région paca en est
elle à 72 % contre 64 % pour le grand
est et 52% en nouvelle athènes face à
cette situation emmanuel macron a
demandé de recruter parmi les étudiants
en médecine les soignants retraités les
militaires et les volontaires de la
réserve sanitaire
ces renforts censées soutenir le travail
des services de réanimation possède
armes
les compétences spécifiques à la
réanimation ça semble complètement
irréaliste
il semble qu'on ait le matériel et la
place physique dans les hôpitaux mais ce
qui va manquer c'est le personnel le
président a l'air de dire qu'on va
trouver des renforts mais il va
apprendre la réanimation lui-même en
quinze jours ce n'est pas mon habitude
de critiquer mais il ne faut pas
annoncer n'importe quoi des sessions
express de trois jours ont démarré en
ile de france pour les infirmiers et les
étudiants en médecine par la société
européenne de soins intensifs et
certains gestes essentiels leur sont
enseignées
mais les médecins alertent tout de même
contre un risque de dégradation des
soins
chaque hôpital doit donc pousser les
murs des programmes et des opérations et
des soins pour accueillir le plus
possible de malades ducobu 19 en région
parisienne où la situation hospitalière
est toujours très tendue et 80% des
opérations doivent être déprogrammée
avec des conséquences potentiellement
graves pour certains patients